well its return now to this year's race
for the American presidency and of
course tonight's New Hampshire primaries
Johnny's from Washington is the demco
strategies Bob Weiner a veteran or Bill
Clinton's White House thank you for
being with us Bob Hillary Clinton is in
New Hampshire and she is trailing
someone who was an unknown independent
senator from Vermont a few months ago
what's gone wrong well you're right at
him it's exploded into a movement for
Bernie and Hillary has got to be quite
careful that it doesn't expand past
Bernie's neighboring state of Vermont
where he's now campaigning in New
Hampshire so it's very possible that
Hillary will lose by a significant
margin today in New Hampshire but when
you get the South Carolina and beyond
and into Super Tuesday she's got a wide
and diverse constituency that's far
beyond the Millennials which she would
love to have but Bernie has captured
them but I mean if she's badly defeated
if he's 10 20 30 points ahead that
really is going to put a hole in her
campaign isn't it well you've stated the
range and that's exactly what it's going
to be is 10 20 or 30 a huge victory
would be less than 10 and expected is
somewhere in the 20s and 31 umber
matters to be honest I think a loss is a
loss and she won Ohio by that much but
she won I mean iOS he won it and she
goes on now to South Carolina and then
Super Tuesday Nevada and all and in all
of those states so I think that she'll
be all right I actually think that it's
going to be fine for her and I think it
will be like losing the first two games
of the World Series and then you win the
next four and I think it's going to be
something like that Adam on the other
hand if you drill down into how people
are voting on the Democratic side it
does seem that she has a fairly
widespread problem with younger women
who might have been expected to come to
her support well I think they still will
and I you know I don't want to say that
the issues Trump Bernie's extreme
positions on
things but there's no way and women must
realize that we're going to go back to
recapturing the debate on health care
which is what Bernie wants to do that
would be a disaster and would allow all
the special interests to get back into
it so Hillary's philosophy of bringing
ninety percent to one hundred percent
coverage and doing it with the
Affordable Care Act as the base is the
right one and she is much broader than
then bernie is on so many issues on
minorities on women's rights where she
said women's rights are human rights on
african-american issues and and black
lives matter Don guns where it does
boggles my mind that liberals would go
for a guy to be honest with you Adam who
voted five times against the Brady Bill
and against and in favor of immunity for
gun manufacturers how do you do that
when mass killings have exploded in the
United States and it's half of them are
with with assault weapons that could be
banned how do you do that so I think
she's got a lot of good issues that will
come further and further front for her
and certainly the debate that we have on
our side Adam I've got to say is so much
better than the one on the Republican
side where the lead candidate is off a
wall on so many issues when I was going
to ask you about that because that who
does Hillary Clinton let's say it's got
to be her who does she want to fight on
the Republican side because isn't there
a danger that if one of these extreme
candidates a trump or a cruise gets the
nomination then we're going to see
former Mayor Bloomberg coming into the
race and that would make it very tricky
for her I don't think and he actually
said that he that he's not likely to
come in if Hillary's the nominee on the
Democratic side I think he's looking at
a protector against a Bernie versus
trump as the race and Trump wants him oh
man Trump is asking for him this morning
on American TV Trump aside my friend
Bloomberg I want him in sure he does
because he will chip away and take a lot
of Hillary support because he's liberal
on choice and he's liberal on guns so of
course the Trump wants him in but the
fact is that I don't think that that for
that very reason I don't think that
Bloomberg is going to go in if Hillary
is the nominee and I think that will
become
sure bye Super Tuesday so therefore she
does want one of the extremists on the
Republican side to get the nomination
well be careful what you wish for
because you know it still is a dangerous
race with Trump despite his dissing
Muslims and women and and and voter
suppression and saying no minimum wage
despite all that he's created a movement
on trade and jobs in Mexico and in China
and all those things there's a message
there so this nativism that he is put
forward is dangerous and I don't take
Trump lightly at all I think he's a will
be even though he's 15 points behind the
Democrats now I think what he did to
brilliantly capture when I think he will
the Republican nomination I think he
will flip on a dime and become more
sensitive more centrist as the general
election approaches cruz i think his
lying and his stealing the carson votes
by saying that Carson dropped out was
unconscionable and he lost a lot Rubio I
think with repeating the same phrase
five times and everybody making fun of
it and now he's being called ro bo
instead of Rubio I think that puts him
out of it I think Kasich actually has a
shot at it Adam I think Christie has a
shot at it and and I think some of the
others Jeff even now has added a little
bit of a shot at it although have a bush
a guy you're going for a crash okay for
Clinton Trump is the most likely pair of
finalists in the American president race
but we thank you very much they were
talking to us